я нагадую що у цій справі відсутні
практично відсутня суперечка фактах
промови це підписання президентом зазначено
ніхто не каже що порошенко
тиснув на кошенята змінюється 27 стаття
пітбуль його не до сахаліні ніхто не
говорить про порошенка як написано в
законі загрожувала жваво обіцяв йому щось
діяв навколо так далі ми знаємо як
виглядає коли президент когось до
чомусь схиляє
щоб далеко не ходити вчорашню історію
про відставку глави національного банку
про який сьогодні з'ясовується що там
була 2 бесіда 1 більш ввічливо та інша
більш пряма у кабінеті президента
які закінчилися написанням зору в
відставці ось ось це так виглядає коли
президент когось до чогось схиляє